it's gorgeous but yeah so um but this is
a serious thing
what what
is serious a thing
what did you say is it seriously
no because that's what I the reason why
I said that is because of that attitude
what what you just did you understood me
the first time no I didn't
I thought you said it's serious a thing
we've been talking about radio a lot
today SiriusXM serious black so you're
saying you you asked me Sue is Sirius FM
I think I don't know do you think that I
would say that like 20 yeah no not even
20 but give me a real what's the
evidence for the 2016 said he could say
that
um you know what's more in fact they
used to call a pre-recorded phone line
where they're playing girls gone Wild's
commercials on audio Yeah Yeah is a
serious a thing is Sirius a thing I'm
having a fever dream right now is it
serious your thing oh yeah yeah okay
yeah it's going good
why what's wrong this is great I don't
know what do you mean you feel paranoid
no no I I I feel like you've been very
funny today
we've been riffing in a good way you
know what I mean yeah it's weird you
know what I mean yeah yeah I just I'm
loving it it's the nose talk all the
stuff about the nose is getting to me I
I understand that and I I backed away
from your nose I'm just so glad you're
here because if it's not your nose it's
my nose yeah you're number one here yeah
beautiful ethnic knows as well yeah I
want to get a nose job I think that's no
no no no no no no you can't you can't
why because you're gonna look like
somebody said something else that we
don't want to see Jennifer Gray Jennifer
Grace [__] up her life really [__]
up yeah she had a beautiful beautiful
prominent yeah like a witch
that's the phone number
yeah but she's still beautiful even with
a nose job yeah I think front on I'm a
10. from the side no 6.7 to me
truth talk yeah right you're a 10 in my
eyes thank you Bobby and I'll tell you
why why is that
number one right your Kip
your hip hip yeah am I not saying you
said Kip here's let's stop for a second
am I having a stroke
I think you're because I feel like
everything I'm saying you guys like I
said it's your hip and then you guys
said Kip and then I was like oh my God
I'm losing my mind I think you're just
speaking pigeon honestly it's crazy do
you understand why I thought you said
SiriusXM five minutes ago
I was serious right right but Gilbert am
I not making sense right now and I'm not
no you are I could I can decipher but
you're just saying the wrong words but I
understand you okay all right so here's
the deal you're talking like an SAT
question
all right so here here's the deal guys
all right I'm going through something
right now and I'm not privy or aware
that I'm going through it so every time
I say something right that doesn't make
any sense or the word isn't clear well
let's do a hand signal and tell me
without even saying a word Prince is
going to be this all right do that
[__] loose okay do that do that I
gotta defend you I have to defend you I
think you were trying to say Kip
yeah it's slang for sleep in English
terms yeah
I'm sleep are you sleeping no I about to
die
it makes sense no you're complimenting
me this is great let's go back please 10
out of 10.
you know um you can tell by the lineups
and where you know because we perform
you know probably in the best lineups in
the LA has to offer would you agree or
disagree yeah fortunately right we have
all the big ones perform where we
perform and you're always on the lineups
right and um there's always a feeling of
like oh this is gonna be a great show
because Trevor's on it you think 100 oh
wow that's so cool 100 because you're so
visible online like tick tocks and
social media and stuff like every like
the couple of dates that no offense that
I've brought to the Improv I've said oh
my God introduce me or whatever yeah I
mean so I know that